11h55 ce matin les portes de la prison
saint joseph s'ouvrait le fourgon
cellulaire transportant klaus barbie se
diriger vers le palais du sis de lyon
mais un quart d'heure avant le transfert
la circulation sur les quais de saône
avait été interrompue 12h05 klaus barbie
arrive au palais de justice mais avant
l'ouverture de ce procès maître vergès
l'avocat de klaus barbie dénoncent déjà
l'aspect médiatique de ce procès il est
choqué il est indigné d'un procès qui
est préparé comme un lynchage de
l'exhibition dans la ville où il est
présenté comme un coupable avant tout
jugement
il est choqué et indigné de ce que dans
les écoles des professeurs non seulement
parlent de la des camps de déportation
mais le fond des termes tels que c'est
bas rhin c'est lui qui semble
responsable de cela avant qu'un tribunal
n'en ai jugé
dix minutes après l'arrivée de barbie
une dizaine de membres de l'association
des fils et filles des déportés juifs de
france sont arrivés auprès du stif pour
remettre un bouquet de roses
multicolores
ap hâte car suède mais dès 11h30 le
public se présenter devant le palais de
justice seules les 50 premières
personnes ont été admises dans la salle
d'audience
je demande au service d'autres
d'introduire l'accusé sidibé 13h05 klaus
barbie menottes aux mains fait son
entrée dans la salle et gagne le box des
accusés le président serge dunis demande
à klaus barbie
comprenez vous suffisamment le français
poursuivent l'était pas réponse des
interprètes
il veut parler en allemand messieurs et
mesdames et messieurs les avocats de la
partie civile dans la salle plus de 700
journalistes suivent ce procès pour
représentant 250 médias dont 25 chaînes
de télévision mais écoutez déjà les
réactions du public
je dirais personnellement j'avais les
larmes aux yeux en pensant aux 7500
juifs déportés depuis lyon alors que
l'accusé rien était extrêmement
satisfait je crois que c'est tout le
climat qui nous sépare indique-t-il
c'est impressionnant c'est
impressionnant l'impression qu'une toute
une et toute une époque est en procès de
ces procès d'une époque et un témoin que
tout à l'heure qui est dit n'est pas
venu là pour la vengeance et je pense
que qu'il a raison c'est pour symbole
qui pour il faut vous aussi
enfin bon ne pas oublier ça met mal à
l'aise quand thomas barbier avec son
oncle plaisante un petit peu avec son
interprète et puis bon maître vergès
enfants nés acr nous fait mal et